Ramadan prayers explode into violence as
Israeli forces storm Alex and mosque
by a stun grenade tear gas and rubber
coated steel bullets
several Palestinians are wounded
eyewitnesses claiming some Medics were
prevented from reaching them
videos showing armed troops forcibly
removing Palestinians from the Alexa
compound
tensions intensified Elsewhere on the
streets of occupied East Jerusalem an
armed Israeli settler was blamed for
shooting and enduring a Palestinian
teenager near the village of silwan
he was carried through the old city and
taken to hospital
that's where Israeli forces confronted
Palestinian protesters denouncing the
earlier violence
I think what we see today is a very
serious provocation and it will
definitely lead to an isolation and
maybe this is exactly what this Israeli
government wants they want to distract
attention from their internal division
through them from the demonstrations
that are taking place inside Israel
against this government and they want to
drag the whole region into a total total
explosion
earlier on Wednesday Israeli forces
stormed the mosque and fired stun
grenades during Ramadan prayers
[Music]
bishopers are barricading themselves
inside
videos showed women and children crying
for help as Israeli forces beat
worshipers with batons that resulted in
at least 12 Palestinians being injured
more than 400 others were arrested
Islam's third holiest site is once again
at the heart of tensions the United
Nations security Council will convene an
emergency session on Thursday to discuss
recent violence and occupied East
Jerusalem with Ramadan Passover and
Easter holidays overlapping this coming
weekend tensions are running High Ben
tonquist Al Jazeera
is the assistant secretary-general of
the Arab League and he says Palestinians
need protection now
this is a very tense situation and we
not only of course condemn it and we lay
the blame totally and squarely on the
Israeli government
this is a political organization you can
do political and diplomatic work and
this is exactly what we are set out to
do we are going to work politically and
diplomatically to expose what Israel has
been doing it's not that we need another
excuse from the Israeli occupation
forces to storm in the Al-Aqsa mosque
they they never run out of excuses they
always tell you that there would be
youth barricading amassing guns and so
on that's that's uh we've heard this so
many times it's it is almost irrelevant
at this point this is a government that
is bent on harming the Palestinian
population on using all sorts of
violence and extreme course in order to
make them
comply with its will and it's not going
to happen we know it's not going to
happen anyone who has a little knowledge
about the situation would have told you
a month ago two months ago that in
Ramadan things are going to flare up
because in Ramadan they use maximum
force and the Palestinians who come to
the mosque to pray are not going to take
this force all that peacefully so it's
going to be there we're going to be
flashes